hey everyone this is National Master
Costa kutki here for chess.com and today
we're going to be covering how to play
the Queen's Gambit accepted after the
beginning moves D4 D5 and C4 the Queen's
Gambit black now plays DT C4 and this
opening is known as the Queen's Gambit
accepted after white plays E3 we
immediately see the main point behind
his opening he wants to play Bishop
takes C4 after he recaptures his Pawn
he's going to be playing for having more
space and better control in the center
meanwhile black should try to
Counterattack White Center and
ultimately strive for peace activity
first let's take a look and see what
happens if black plays B5 trying to hold
on to his extra Pawn white should now
play A4 immediately attacking Black's
Pawn chain we can quickly realize that
black has no good way of holding on to
both of these pawns moves like A6 fail
because white will take on B5 and black
cannot recapture because his Rook on A8
is
hanging similarly a move like C6 also
doesn't work because white will take on
B5 and if black recaptures white will
play Queen F3 winning a lot of
material this means that black should
simply not play B5 and try and move like
Knight F6 just starting his development
and preparing to attack White Center
after white recaptures the pawn black
plays E6 white plays Knight F3 and black
plays C5 attacking White
Center now White Castles and black plays
A6 the point behind A6 is to play B5
gaining space on the queen side and
preparing to develop a bishop to B7
where it's going to be really active
here white has two main options the
first option is to play
A4 the good thing about A4 is that it
stops Black's idea of playing B5 the
drawback
is that it gives Black full control over
the B4
Square now after black plays Knight C6
Knight C3 and Bishop E7 black very
shortly is going to capture on D4 and
after white recaptures he's going to
have an isolated Queen
pawn and now we're going to have pretty
much normal play where one sign has an
isolated Queen Pawn white is going to
try to prove that this Pawn is a
strength and try to activate his pieces
with moves like Knight E5
Bishop G5 Rook E1 and try to play either
for the D4 D5 Pawn break or for an
attack against Black's King side
meanwhile black is gonna try to blockade
this Pawn on D4 and the way he's going
to do that is by maneuvering his C6
Knight to the square D5 using the B4
Square after he does that he's going to
develop his light score Bishop to D7 and
then to C6 where he's going to continue
to strengthen his control over the D5
square if black can hold on to this
blockade he's going to have very good
counter playay because White's D4 Pawn
is going to be very
weak if white wants to try a different
approach he should play Bishop B3
allowing black to expand on the queen
side with B5 now after A4 attacking
Black's pawns black should push forward
with B4 and now white has the option of
playing E4 a very sharp and aggressive
Pawn sacrifice
if black accepts this Pawn White's going
to play Rook E1 and after Black's Knight
Retreats white can play D5 and white has
a very strong attack in the center
against Black's King so this is not what
black wants black should instead play C
takes
D4 after Knight bd2 Bishop B7 E5 and
Knight D7 we've reached a really
complicated position black has an extra
Pawn on on D4 but it's not so easy for
white to recapture this Pawn without
losing his E5 Pawn white should try to
play for the
initiative white should play moves like
Rook E1 Knight C4 Bishop G5 Rook C1 and
ultimately play against Black's
weaknesses in his own position meanwhile
black should play moves like Knight C6
Rook C8 Queen C7 Bishop B7 and Castle
King side and try to either win this E5
Pawn or simply complete his development
and gain counter play in the
center thanks a lot for listening this
is National Master KY KUSI and I'll see
you around on chess.com